aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous allez d lui
poser la question vous voulez la voir
oui c'est Golen c'est Golen explique
elle est
là bravo elle
arrive bonjour bonjour ça va bien oh là
là personne pas que je me déconcentre he
qu'est-ce que vous sentez bon vous vous
êtes une fraîcheur de vie vous êtes un
Hollywood shungum
je don je donner sur fridance S suorol
c'est comment allez-vous ça va bien ils
ont une question à vous poser V savoir
si on se parle oui madame je voulais
savoir si dans la semaine quand voilà
vous parlez à Cyril au téléphone vous lu
envoyz des messag non non non non est-ce
qu'il y a des messages estce des app je
lu envoie le message de du du choix du
sujet que je propose et est-ce qu'il
vous répond surtout oui oui oui c'est
vrai qu' elle est incroable jeudi je
voudrais parler de ça oui c'est tout
mais il est aimable il vous envoie smile
ou c'est min non non non c'est très
professionnel a pas il y a pas de tigre
du Bengal très respectueux et très
professionnel et j'ai dit à séolen comme
je l'adorais comme on était content de
l'avir auprès de nous et on prépare
d'autres choses avec sgolen et on va
voir c'est quand on fait pas la culture
aujourd'hui non la semaine praine
semaine prochaine on aura une petite
aussi petite la minute culture deolen en
plus en
plusation et pour le même
prix tiens à le dire aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va parler de la hausse du
coût de la vie et le taux d'inflation
alors ça où est l'arnaque ça on dire où
est l'arnaque et c'esten elle va nous
dire oui alors c'est un sujet technique
un peu compliqué mais comme tous les
jeudis c'est un peu la
séquence éducation civique c'est-à-dire
faire comprendre avec des mots simples
sans édulcorer la complexité des choses
parce que sinon on a toujours
des dirigants qui nous disent c'est trop
compliqué on va pas vous expliquer et
Cera qu'est-ce qu'on a entendu cette
semaine hier on a entendu que le taux du
de rémunération du livré d'épares
populaires baissait oui entendu on nous
a dit le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances a dit ça va baisser de 6 à 5 %
parce que l'inflation baisse ouais et
puis après on a entendu compris dans du
président de la République qui aurait
peut-être une taxe sur l'électricité et
le gaz de 10 % déjà c'est pas très
cohérent vous voyez et quand on fait nos
courses est-ce que on constate que
l'inflation que la hausse des prix est à
3 % non beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup
plus les prix alimentaires on sa ont
augmenté de entre 10 et 25 % les prix de
l'énergie ont augmenté de 20 % les prix
du carburant on en a parlé et les loyers
les charges et cetera donc vous voyez
qu'il y a une forme d'arnaque d'où vient
cette arnaque c'est qu'on nous fait
croire que le le chiffre de l'inflation
c'est le chiffre de la hausse du coût de
la vie c'est ça que je vouis vous
expliquer que c'est que le taux
d'inflation le taux d'inflation c'est un
chiffre théorique qui est donné par
l'INC c'estàd l'Institut de la
statistique donc un chiffreiciel qui est
donné tous les mois et tous les ans
qu'est-ce qui nous dit ce chiffre
aujourd'hui c'est que l'année dernière
les prix ont augmenté d'un peu plus de 5
% et qu'en 2003 en 2023 ils ont augmenté
de 4,9 % est-ce que quand vous faites
les courses les prix nont augmenté que
de
4,9% pour l'alimentaire et pourtant ce
chiffre est très important parce que
c'est là-dessus qu'on se base pour
augmenter le salaire minimum pour
augmenter les retraites et cetera
c'est-à-dire qu'on se fait quand même
bien avoir au
passage et pourquoi cette différence
parce que c'est un chiffre théorique
voyez qui est calculé à partir de 21
groupes de produits mais ça veien mais
vous ne dépensez pas la même chose selon
que vous gagnez un SMIC ou selon que
vous gagnez 10 fois le SMIC vous voulez
parler de Val et pourtant c'est non je
parlais de la min de l'éducation avant
voilà et pourtant c'est exactement voyez
la même structure comme si vous preniez
le même cadit or moins vous gagnez plus
vous dépensez proportionnellement en
alimentation en en électricité que si
vous habitez en milieu rural vous avez
plus de transport si vous avez des
enfants vous allez dépenser plus en
alimentation si et cetera donc en
fonction de la taille de la famille de
votre niveau de vie de de l'endroit où
vous habitez si vous êtes dépensez
pareil que si vous êtes locataire et C
voyez bien que vous n'z pas avoir la
même consommation donc ce qui est
intégré dans dans ce chiffre c'est aussi
des prix qui baissent par exemple ou des
prix que vous n'allez pas vous utiliser
en fonction de vos revenus par exemple
il y a aussi des prix de l'équipement
électroménager de
l'informatique des produits
textiles des produits de de loisirs le
coût de l'hôtel Le coû des transports en
avion et cetera mais quand vous êtes
avec des niveau moy ou ou modeste vous
ne dép faites pas ces dépenses et donc
la vra la vérité c'est qu'il faudrait
tenir compte c'est-à-dire produire un
indice des prix en fonction des tranches
de revenus person le fait pas B parce
que ça permet de de d'écraser le la
vérité et donc de de moins
indexer voyez de de comment faire une
pression à la baisse sur les
revendications d'augmentation et ceter
nous car la seconde chose que vous
pouvez observer c'est que quand ça
baisse c'est tout de suite répercuté
c'estàdire là il nous dit c'est l'année
prochaine moins 3 % c'est le cours
d'année il baisse tout de suite le taux
mais on on on n pas encore à cette
baisse et inversement quand les prix
augmentent vous avez vu c'est tout de
suite c'est tout de suite c'est c'est on
attend que ça non plutôt on attend que
ça se répercute la hausse des taux
d'intérêt sur les livré d'épargne
deuxième chose il baisse sur les livré
d'épargne populaire mais c'est
scandaleux vous savez combien il faut
gagner combien il faut gagner quel est
le plafond de revenus pour avoir le
droit d'ouvrir un livraet d'épargne
populaire qui sont les gens qui ont le
droit d'ouvrir ce livret d'épargne les
plus modestes les plus modestes 1800 €
par mois donc c'est tous les gens qui
vont gagner moins de 1800 € par mois qui
qui qui mettent allez 90 % de leur
revenus dans dans l'énergie dans
l'alimentation c'est-à-dire des prix qui
ont explosé de plus de 20 % V en plus
devoir retirer 1 % de rémunération de
leur épargne et en plus on leur annonce
10 % d'augmentation de l'électricité
donc ça voyez ça c'est tout à faitandme
stir du marché faudrait pas sortir du
marché européen de l'énergie absolument
c'est pour ça que je viens à la question
deénerg l'impression qu'il est pervers
ce marché ouis et juste pour terminer
sur l'alimentation avant de passer à
l'énergie c'est que on a observé mais
c'est les statistiques officielles que
l'augmentation des prix
de l'alimentation était dû pour les 2
tiers à l'augmentation des marges des
profits de l'industrie
agroalimentairirees et des grandes
surfaces de distribution c'est pas
honteux ça souvent dépend des
agriculteurs d'ailleurs je donne
l'exemple des des clémentines que vous
avez dû acheter aussi en décembre les
clémentines qui étaient acheté 1 € aux
agriculteurs elles étaient vendues 9 €
sur les marchés vous avez vu entre 8 et
9 € donc clémentines weekend là aussi il
y a quoi y aurait quoi qu'est-ce que
demandent les associations de
consommateurs c'est que ses profils et
ces marges soi rendu publiqu pour que
les citoyens puissent voir ça fasse une
pression à la baisse et qu'elle soit
réglementé c'est dire qu'on leur dit
c'est pas plus de 5 % c'est pas plus de
10 % c'est pas plus que vos coups de de
transport et cetera donc qu'est-ce qui
s' met plein les poches les transports
les grandes les les grandes surfaces les
les supermarchés et et l'industrie
agroalimentaire la papaille à 12
€ PAP il faut pas acheter de papaille ça
vient d'où la papaille pas papa et
[Rires]
maman carbone alors l'énergie
effectivement parénergie dans un instant
sgolen parce que moi aussi j'ai besoin
de gagner de l'oseille on va se
retrouver dans un instant avec sgolen
qui est extraordinaire vous avez un beau
stabilon ah ça coupe là il y non dans 2
minutes on va êre en pub je vis juste
parler de votre surligneur je
vous c'est le
mien pourquoi C Go elle nous disait rien
quand elle était au gouvernement
je disais
déjàucors elle pas bien sûr je me suis
j'ai même annulé les
cotaxes mais bien sûr j'ai fait j'ai pas
fait la taxe carbone au contraire je
l'ai enlevé quand j'étais minist là
c'est une nouvelle taxe qui arrive
n'ésite pas tu peux la secouer un
peu V j'ai toujours dit ça d'ailleurs
même pendant ma campagne de 2007 je
parlais déjà de l'indice des il y avait
du d'ailleurs un indice indicatif des
prix qui avait été fait à un moment tu
entends ça é parce que vous avez entendu
que 80 % des Français ét ont été
effarésentendre l'annonce de hausse de
10 % févri jusqu'à 10 % d'une nouvelle
taxe sur l'électricité comme si la taxe
carbone et les gilets jaunes n'avaient
pas servi de leçon alors on voit bien
déjà l'opération de communication qui se
prépare voulez que je vous la
raconte il nous disent 10 % 10 % 10 %
donc ils vont annoncer un peu moins ils
vont annoncer pas et ca tout en nous
disant que inflation n'est qu'à 4 déjà
ça devrait pas être plus de 4 bah oui
parce que ils ont qui d'intérêt sous
prétexte que l'inflation sera à 3 donc
ça devrait être déjà pas plus de tris
alors ils nous disent 10 pourquon dise
vous voyez ça a failli être 10 mais
finalement c'est que 9 et demi vous vous
rendez compte come on est gentil bâtard
donc vous allez voir attendons le
chiffre et et à ce moment-là il faudra
répondre ben non d'abord vous dites
c'est TR et ça devrait être zéro voilà
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi ça
devrait être zé c'est ce qu'on veut
parce que quand il y a eu le bouclier
tarifaire c'est-à-dire au fond que
l'État a gelé et a remboursé c'est un
peu technique mais c'est un peu complexe
à rembourser jusqu'à 13 milliards parce
que les les prix de l'énergie étaient
très élevés et pour maintenir les prix
plus bas il a remboursé une différence
aujourd'hui les prix de l'énergie au
niveau mondial ont baissé ils sont
revenus au niveau d'avant c'est-à-dire
que si et donc l'état là va économiser
13 milliards ça ve dire que si remet une
taxe en fait c'est qu'il va rattraper
une partie de la décision de baisse
qu'il avait fait donc aujourd'hui les
prix sont revenus au niveau d'avant il y
a aucune raison de mettre une taxe et
donc la décision à prendre c'est de
rendre ça transparent pour que les
Français comprennent mais surtout en
effet c'est de sortir du marché européen
de l'électricité ça je le dis depuis le
début on n était pas quand j'étais
ministre de l'énergie dans ce marché
ultralibéral o on impose la concurrence
de tous contre tous et on est obligé SAF
qu quand il faut s'aligner vers le haut
et aujourd'hui la France qui produit
l'électricité moins cher que les autres
pays européens est obligé de s'aligner
c'est-à-dire d'aligner ses prix au plus
haut niveau c'est-à-dire notamment au
niveau du prix du gaz ça veut dire que
nous nous payons nous les Français nous
payons la production d'électricité et
nous sommes obligés de repayer une
deuxième fois pour nous aligner sur les
prix européens les plus élevés et donc
les Espagnols sont sortis de cette
mécanique ça V absolument aussi sortir
de cette mécanique et ça va être un des
enjeux de la campagne pour les élections
européennes voilà j'ai
[Applaudissements]
fini vous avez compris
merci à
bientôt elle l'avait dit maman elle
l'avait dit quand tu été au gouvernement
voilà je te dis et surtout je l'ai fait
par que j'ai supprimé la taxex je vous
dire un truc ma oui aime bien sa mère
non mais elle vous adore c'est bien je
pense les fils qui aiment leur mère
c'est bien oui bah oui et ben à l'époque
et et ben je vous le dirai mais elle a
pas voté pour moi si non
euh la prochaine fois la prochaine fois
la prochaine fois voilà merci che
merci
merci ça bien expliqué sur l'électricité
ah j'adore